[Music]
foreign
here is the timeline and ancient history
of dragons and other monsters in the
world of Game of Thrones and House of
the Dragon let's get to it
before 12000 BC the first creatures and
monsters to be chronologically described
were the Giants and Children of the
forests of Westeros
10000 BC orex an ancient dragon during
the age of the first men was killed by a
dragon slayer called servant of the
mirror Shield this is one of the oldest
human Dragon interactions in that world
10 000 BC dragons are also said to have
once roosted on Battle Isle until the
first high tower put an end to them not
much is known about what kind of dragons
and if they were just wyverns 8000 BC
the long night Begins whereby the
deadliest Monsters of the world of
Westeros came from the north these were
the white walkers which are Undead
monstrosities
5000 BC in the region of the 14 fires
the first Valerian Dragons Were hatched
from dragon eggs discovered by the
ancient valyrians with them came a
golden age of magic and fire in essence
4700 BC the guest Curry walls ended with
the fifth war in which all gears is
utterly destroyed by the Freehold the
valyrians destroyed the city's walls and
streets using her numerous dragons
4000 to 3000 BC somewhere during that
time terrex was a dragon written by
Genera Belarus and they both flew South
to sothorius and she returned to Valeria
after three years having only found
endless jungle deserts and mountains
700 BC during the second spice war after
the water Wizards killed three dragons
the dragonlords of valyria responded by
sending around 300 dragons to defeat a
250 000 strong Army of the rhoyanar
314 BC using Arcane Arts the valyrians
built a castle whose towers are shaped
to look like dragons giving it its name
Dragonstone which later became the
stronghold of House Targaryen
120 BC it is unknown as to what exact
date the birth of valerian the black
dread actually is but it was before the
doom and hence around 120 BC since he
was old enough to fly to Dragonstone
120 to 100 BC some of the small folk of
Dragonstone claimed that a cannibal
lived on the island even before the
targaryens arrived in Warren 14 BC which
makes it around the same age as Valerio
102 BC the Doom of valyria occurs
whereby the entire Freehold is destroyed
by volcanoes and a result in fire this
killed off most dragons except for the 5
Targaryen dragons and a couple of others
90 to 60 BC the first dragon to be born
after Doom the birth of miraxius is not
really exact and can only be estimated
but she was born before Vega and was the
second largest dragon at that time
52 BC the second dragon to be born in
Dragonstone the birth of Vega is more
precise and she eventually became the
largest dragon after Valerian died of
old age
220 BC during aegon's Conquest The Three
Dragons were used to deadly effect
essentially becoming the winning Factor
Valerian miraxis and Vega were adults
and gigantic by this time
10 AC during the Danish walls a scorpion
bolt managed to pierce the dragon
maraxis in the eye and kill the dragon
this was the first dragon death in
Westeros after the conquest
11 AC this was the birth of the first
dragon after aegon's conquest and she
was called Quicksilver she was a
beautiful dragon with silver white
scales and spat out Flames that were
also White
30-37 AC the birth of the second
generation westerosi dragons which were
vermouth Silverwing sheep Steeler and
dream fire all became deadly Dragons by
the time of the dance
43 AC for the first time since the Doom
of valyria dragon fought dragon in the
sky Belair and the black dread kills
quicksilver in a swift Battle Above the
God's eye
50 to 60 AC the third generation
westerosi dragons which include melees
the Red Queen and carax is the blood
worm will hatched both became important
dragons for the blacks
90 to 100 AC the fourth generation
Dragons Were hatch which included Cyrax
and sea smoke these dragons were smaller
and grew slower but were more agile and
Nimble in the air
100 AC the birth of Greg house and
deserion Greg host was a wild Dragon
while Cesarion was known as the blue
Queen
107 AC described as the most beautiful
Dragon Sunfire was born which was bonded
to King aegon II he was a golden dragon
with pinkish wings and he was born in
this year
114 to 117 AC the three dragons that
were born into the Valerian sons of
Queen rhaenera Vermax erax and dyraxis
were born between these years
120 to 123 AC the both of the smaller
dragons which were only big enough to
ride during the dance they include
stormcloud Strikers Markle and Moon
Dancer
129 AC the death of arax by Vega and
also melees by a combined attack by Vega
and Sunfire directly caused the
escalations to war in the dance of the
dragons
130 AC the death of all the Targaryen
dragons in many battles during the
Targaryen Civil War all except for
Silver Wing and cheap Steeler who flew
away and warning who was recently
hatched from an egg
153 AC The Last Dragon was born during
the reign of aegon III and it was sickly
and around the size of a house cat aegon
then became known as the dragon's Bane
298 AC after 8 000 years of inactivity
the white walkers were cited by the
wildlings and the men of the Night's
Watch by this time they had become just
fairy tales
299 AC after 150 years of no dragons the
ritual done in Carl drogo's cremation
gave birth to Daenerys dragons which
were drogon rhaegal and viserion
299-307 AC the white walkers begin to
gather their army of the Dead to
eventually destroy the wall and March on
the living while at the same time
daenerys's dragons drogon rhaegar and
viserion were growing at a fast rate
eventually becoming adults
307 AC the death of viserion and rhaegal
the Syrian was killed by the ninth King
and rhaegar was killed by scorpion bolts
shot from euron greyjoy's ship
307 AC during the Battle of Winterfell
the army of the living defeats the army
of the dead and the night King was
killed by Arya Stark and this ended the
time of the white walkers
307 AC after Jon Snow killed Daenerys
drogon melts the iron throne and flies
away with daenerys's body to the east of
asses him becoming the last dragon to
live in this world
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam